les images sont saisissantes elles ont
fait le tour du monde depuis des mois
dans un froid mordant des hommes des
femmes des familles risquent parfois
leur vie pour traverser pour certains
c'est le rêve américain qui vire au
cauchemar
aux etats unis les frontières se
resserre
au canada une autre vision
ouverture la compassion la générosité et
tué la mère faso et et de se protéger et
de promouvoir un ovale heures et nos
communautés fortes ont coûté les motards
in que pour canal marron mano ces deux
perspectives contribuer à faire du
canada un pôle d'attraction dans un
contexte mondial où des dizaines de
millions de personnes sont déracinées de
leur pays d'origine
du jamais vu dans l'histoire du monde
[Musique]
en deux mois un millier de demandeurs
d'asile dits illégaux sont entrés au
canada par la frontière du sud
la grande majorité entre au québec mais
aussi au manitoba et en colombie
britannique
la peur au ventre ils sont prêts à tout
pour se mettre en sécurité dont
l'objectif se sauvegarder ma avec l'
invité de monsieur jack
c'est différent toutes les choses se
sont divisés
et pour ceux qui les représentent
l'enjeu est critique
honnêtement les enjeux sont énormes il y
a des gens qui seront expulsés et risque
la mort parce que des erreurs ont été
commises
dans notre domaine
[Musique]
bonjour soit 6 jours l'art de bien vivre
vous avez vos documents avez vous écrit
des raisons pour laquelle voulait pas
retourner en haïti sur l'autre fait
comme vous avait demandé ces deux hommes
sont arrivés au québec il y a dix jours
nous allons préserver leur anonymat pour
ne pas nuire à leur demande d'asile est
révélée 2 le 12 mars
avez vous traversé ensemble oui
traversant sans manquer leur histoire
est typique celle de centaines d'autres
qui traverse depuis quelques mois la
frontière du sud
ils ont demandé l'asile aux états unis
où il vivait depuis trois ans mais ils
ont fui de peur d'être expulsé en haïti
avant que leur demande soit traitée
je sais que les agents d'immigration les
haïti et donc deux personnes comme vous
que vous connaissez qui avait demandé
sept de réfugié aux états unis ils ont
été convoqués par les autorités
d'immigration a été dans la rue ils ont
été arrêtés dans la rue et il y avait
une demande d'asile aux états unis comme
vous et le ils ont été expulsés vers
haïti
les deux hommes ont voyagé par autobus
de l'état du delaware à plattsburgh
de là ils ont pris un taxi jusqu'à la
frontière le chauffeur les a déposés ici
à rock sound un petit chemin de campagne
situé entre deux postes frontaliers
à 45 minutes de montréal quand nous
sommes passés on a pu constater la
popularité de ce passage un secret de
polichinelle pour ceux qui cherchent à
entrer au canada
et vous savez que vous êtes sur six
arrestations prenant très élégant
maintenant vous êtes entré aux femmes à
gauche ici
oh j'ai l'habitude natale et je la lis
le journal est attendu pour moi est la
situation
donc c'est ce que je crois c'est que
vous avez eu plus par les médias oui
vous pouvez aller au canada est passé
pendant serment par la frontière pour
demander statut de réfugié
[Musique]
nous avons rencontré de l'autre côté de
la frontière une autre personne qui rêve
du canada mais erika et coin ici aux
etats-unis avec ses deux enfants qu'il
ya nos problèmes au real à la casse à
pau au salvador la présence des gangs
criminalisés est un problème endémique
erika raconte que membre d'un gagne a
tué son beau frère
son conjoint l'a dénoncé à la police
craignant pour sa vie et s'est enfui
rapidement au canada
eric affirme que pour se venger le gagne
s'en serait pris à elle ils peuvent y
aller nero et locascio dragonica est le
plus rapide sur le lac assal et pedro
surtout quand tu es un héros est
[Musique]
effrayée eric a fait ses valises et
payer un passeur pour se rendre au
canada pendant 47 jours ses enfants et
elle ont traversé le guatemala le
mexique les états unis jusqu'à beau flow
collé sur la frontière canadienne
son rêve son but rejoindre son conjoint
au canada privés loués à des écouteurs
et moustiques et qui accueille nice
plupart des formats des éléments sont
pas appliquées insa zunino doter nos
familles
son conjoint qui habite à toronto ne
peut la parrainer parce qu'il n'a pas
encore de statut ici erika doit trouver
un autre moyen d'entrer au pays
des milliers de gens en route pour le
canada s'arrête ici
comerica et ses enfants au centre des
deux réfugiés vivent et abu flon
c'est d'ici qu'est rica et mis en
contact avec un cabinet d'avocats de
toronto
une équipe est formée pour s'occuper de
ce dossier particulier il communique
avec elle par skype avec l'aide d'un
interprète
bonjour eric 1 comme je voulais dit dans
notre conversation précédente
un gros offert d'aider votre cause erika
apprend que si elles entrent légalement
par un poste frontalier canadien sa
demande d'asile sera probablement refusé
youtube et vous pourriez être retourné
aux états unis immédiatement
et bien sûr si vous êtes peu poussé aux
états unis après avoir été refusé par le
canada vous pourriez vous et vos filles
être emprisonné et ricains et ses
enfants seraient possiblement expulsé au
salvador
c'est au calme et mis eric fait face à
un dilemme entrés illégalement et
risquer la vie de ces jeunes enfants ou
respecter la loi en faisant sa demande
d'asile aux états unis et couper ses
enfants de leur père
si rica est prise au piège c'est en
raison d'une entente entre les états
unis le canada qu'on appelle l'entente
des tiers pays sûrs
le principe est que les deux pays
respecte la convention sur les réfugiés
si vous voulez faire une demande de
statut de réfugié vous devez le faire
dans le premier pays où vous arrivez
l'effet pervers c'est que les gens pour
se soustraire à aux effets de cette
entente ont pas d'autre alternative de
contourner et pourquoi parce que si on
fait une demande de l'intérieur du
canada
on est en sol canadien et l'entente bien
elle ne s'applique pas dès qu'on met le
pied au canada
l'effet pervers se fait ressentir
aujourd'hui depuis le début de l'année
près de 700 demandeurs d'asile sont
entrés au québec pendant cette période
alors que toutes les caméras sont
tournés sur eux
plus d'un millier de demandeurs d'asile
sont entrés légalement aux postes
frontaliers aux aéroports toutes les
demandes devraient en principe être
entendu dans les 60 jours
advenant un refus des procédures d'appel
existent et peuvent rendre le processus
beaucoup plus long match qui m'avait dit
qu'il y avait un problème avec l'un
d'eux pouvez vous m'en parlez gaza et
gabri a fait sa demande d'asile à
toronto il ya douze ans il est
originaire d'asmara en erythrée où sévit
un des régimes les plus répressifs
d'afrique à une époque vous vous êtes
caché pourquoi je vais très peur des
autorités tout aux hommes
je pensais qu'il allait me renvoyer en
erythrée d'y être chrétiens
pentecôtistes une religion interdit dans
son pays et soutient avoir été persécuté
la commission de l'immigration ne l'a
pas crue les procédures d'appel se sont
multipliées sans succès
ils étaient détenus sur le point d'être
expulsé lorsqu'il a été mis en contact
avec l'avocate catherine drugs de l'aide
juridique de l'ontario elle
l'accompagnera dans une ultime approche
une demande humanitaire qui lui
permettrait de rester au canada mais
elle le préviens ça pourrait mal tourner
comme vous le savez kassaï nous allons
avoir une décision aujourd'hui je crois
bien que votre demande a été bien
préparé et je suis optimiste
nouveau succès il ya un risque de
détention et si cela arrive
soyez assurés que nous allons nous
battre pour vous faut je ne crois pas
qu'on vous posera beaucoup de questions
aujourd'hui vous allez simplement
connaître la décision après près de
douze ans vous aurez un statut
l'avenir de casteil se joue aujourd'hui
s'il est refusée ils pourraient être
détenus et expulsé sur le champ en
erythrée
[Musique]
vous avez l'air un peu par un tonnerre
j'espère qu'après la décision kassaï
ressortira avec moi et qui sera heureux
c'est ce que nous espérons et hoitz le
pire scénario serait qu'ils ne
ressortent pas et qu'il soit incarcéré
[Musique]
l'impression qui se dégage du
gouvernement américain c'est que les
états unis ne veulent plus être un pays
d'accueil
le décret trompe interdisant l'entrée
aux ressortissants de certains pays
musulmans en est un exemple ou en dehors
aux etats unis les expulsions
s'intensifie et alimente la peur dans ce
contexte ces deux hommes sans papiers
légaux aux états unis avaient toutes les
raisons de craindre les agents
américains
ils ont été d'autant plus surpris de la
tournure des événements pourquoi vous
devez passer illégalement y avait des
agents la houle et aximum
[Musique]
ils ont arrêté les âges américaine
ils nous ont demandé vos papiers oui
vous demander qu'est ce que vous faisiez
et le vous dites que vous voulez pas
assez au canada et là il n'y a pas de
frontières on est à brax and roll
ils vous laissent aller on se débarrasse
êtes vous finalement stéphane handfield
c'est juin des dizaines d'avocats
canadien qui demande au gouvernement
d'abolir l'on tente des tiers pays sûrs
le flot va consomme à continuer et c'est
pour ça que je dis et que plusieurs de
mes collègues me disent également le
gouvernement doit intervenir le
gouvernement libéral le statu quo n'est
plus une solution d'une manière ou d'une
autre
l'entente sur les tiers pays sûrs doit
être révoqué
il pousse les gens à choisir des entrées
de plus en plus dangereuse
plutôt que des postes frontaliers
régulière si nous voulons sérieusement
éviter d'exploser les gens à ce genre de
danger
la réponse est évidente ouvrir les
frontières aux réfugiés
en attendant eric 1 ne peut entrer
légalement au canada
elle doit faire un choix rester aux
etats-unis et demander l'asile ou
contester la légalité de l'entente
nous allons déterminer si elle est la
bonne personne pour contester la
constitutionnalité de l'entente du tiers
pays sûrs
on évoquera que les états unis ne
fournissent pas la protection qu'ils
sont tenus de fournir aux réfugiés
un argument partagé par la prestigieuse
école de droit de l'université mort vers
les états unis ne sont plus un pays
sécuritaire pour ceux qui fuient la
persécution et la violence pour
contester la légalité de cette entente
l'avocat a dubai world propose à erika
de la rejoindre un poste frontalier de
la haine évoquera son droit de contester
l'entente devant les tribunaux canadiens
c'est une décision importante et je ne
veux pas que vous l'appreniez tout de
suite mais c'est risqué et magazines
amis paillis pour qui
m
bouquet terreau pour lui avait mis ses
amis éric 1 est toujours à bord flou la
stratégie n'est pas encore déterminée
d'ici quelques semaines les deux
haïtiens que nous avons rencontré
devraient connaître leur sort
en attendant il avait avec un membre de
leur famille
la 10 ans se sont acceptés comme
réfugiés l'un d'eux aimerait faire venir
sa femme et ses deux enfants qu'il n'a
pas vu depuis trois ans se sont refusés
ils seront retournés aux états unis et
risque d'être détenus puis expulsés vers
haïti ce qui représenterait selon lui un
danger en raison de ses opinions
politiques
est-ce qu'on vous ait déjà menacé oui
aussi à des personnes qui est ko chez
moi pété pouviez me suicider ils ont
trouvé ma femme à la maison
qu'est ce qui est arrivé ils ont violé
ma femme jada visitera les orioles et de
la femme et le zoo dit et ils viennent
me pousuivent n'est pas qu'à valoir le
faire d'où de la preuve sera sur ses
épaules pour obtenir la protection du
canada
il devra convaincre la commission de
l'immigration que sa vie est réellement
en danger
je pense que les gens croient à tort que
c'est un processus à la portée de tous
insulza il est facile d'établir que vous
êtes un réfugié afghan que les gens
viennent ici parce qu'ils recherchent
une vie plus facile
ce n'est pas le cas
ce que vous empêche de dormir le soir
est faux l'incompréhension des gens te
pousse à ce qu'on atteint sur sur
l'immigration sur les réfugiés
ça me fait part ça ça m'inquiète ce
discours un noeud de plus en plus
présents sur la place publique sur les
réseaux sociaux
ce show s'inquiétant le permis de
travail
on pourra en discuter on peut
effectivement faire une demande de
permis de travail
oui si vous le souhaitez je suis ok il
aimerait travailler le plus rapidement
possible
repartir à zéro dans ce nouveau pays
mais surtout ne jamais retourner en
haïti
si ma maison a été incendiée
vous venez me vous n'aimez mais d après
vous me redonne dans la même maison mais
ça a été ça a été le feu vous aider vous
mettre dans une prison à sécurité plus
sécurité qui n'est qu'il n'a pas de feu
plus de 7000 personnes ont été expulsées
du canada l'an dernier les familles des
victimes entre la mémoire de ceux qui
les ont côtoyés
est ce que vous avez eu des clients qui
ont été déportés puis vous saviez que
il était vraiment en danger vous avez
des des questions qui sont warhol qui
viennent me chercher
oui oui comment on vivait avec ça
je me sens impuissant
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur en
hauteur notamment les succès sont
fantastiques at il trahi l'emprunt
contribuer à assurer la sécurité ou
réunir une famille c'est merveilleux
autant gagne un dossier peut être
enivrant autant à perdre est terrible sa
voix est de retour à toronto
nous attendons de connaître le sort de
cas saga bray
comment ça a été vraiment bien qu'est ce
qui s'est passé je crois qu'ils ont
accepté ma demande humanitaire
c'est fantastique en principe il a été
acceptée ce qui est fantastique il est
autorisé à rester vous auriez dû voir
son visage à l'intérieur il était très
ravi finalement way avait presque 12 ans
c'est vraiment fantastique
c'est la meilleure partie de ce travail
fantastique
tu vraiment heureux félicitations vous
avez finalement un statut légal au
canada
merci
[Musique]